- Can I not do this anymore?
Honestly, kinda scared.
(spooky music)
- I hate horror movies.
I get scared really easily.
- I do get scared from them
but I love that feeling.
- The Grudge, Ring
- When A Stranger Calls or I
Know What You Did Last Summer
- Sinister, it's a really good one.
The Conjuring
- That's so not fun.
Like why would you put yourself
through being terrified
for like an hour and a half?
- I really have to go to the bathroom
so I hope you don't play
something really scary
'cause I might pee my pants.
(spooky music)
- [Girl] No, no, no child, no.
No, no (laughs)
Oh my God, no.
- [Blonde girl] I'm like scared.
- Oh ok, I was not expecting that.
- [Dark haired girl] No!
- Since when are they British?
- The echoing is not helping.
- This reminds me of Saw.
- [Dark haired girl] Do
not go with them Danny!
Oh no! (screams)
- That was so random.
- Oh my God.
- What a power to have, to see that.
- Where are his parents?
- I don't know if that actually happened?
- Yeah, 'cause now they're gone.
- Can't he just go to his room?
- He's definitely crazy.
- What?
Talking to his finger.
- He's making direct eye contact with me.
(spooky music)
- [Girl] Hey, Johnny Depp, looking good.
- [Dark haired girl] Oh the crop top.
- Boys should wear crop tops more often.
Ok! Oh!
- Oh my...where's he going?
- Oh shit!
So many things just happened!
Oh my God!
- Oh I was not expecting that.
That's a lot of blood.
- Ok, the human body does not
have that much blood in it.
(spooky music)
- [Dark haired girl]
I feel like somebody's
gonna pop up behind her.
- It's too quiet.
- When her eyes are closed.
- [Red haired girl] She's
too happy, it's not normal.
- [Girl] She's like over
excessively soaping herself.
- Ok there we go.
- Oh my God the door opened!
How does she not see that? (screams)
- Oh my
(laughs)
- [Red haired girl] My goodness.
- Looks like a shark bit her.
- How is she not dead yet?
- Stop. Oh my God.
- This is why I don't shower home alone.
- [Girl] She has to be dead.
- What a time to be alive.
(laughs)
(spooky music)
- [Girl] That's the creepiest
doll I've ever seen.
- (screams) This is a great start.
- Why would you do that?
- I would leave.
- [Dark haired girl] No, don't touch it.
Stop it, you're aggravating it.
- The hair (laughs)
- The expression on the
doll is like really scary.
Is she putting the doll in the fire?
- This woman needs some help.
(laughs)
(screams)
- [Girl] Looks like he's
trying to give her a hickey.
Your average Friday night.
- [Dark haired girl] For a
small doll that is some words.
- Why did she want it
to wake up if it's gonna
do that to her?
- She can just leave her house.
- This woman is gonna die.
(spooky music)
- So many things just happened.
- I'm pretty sure I was
screaming the whole time.
- Yeah.
- For it's time period I'd
say it looked pretty good.
- But for now, it seemed a little dated.
- You wouldn't really see
much of what just happened
in a horror movie today.
- A lot of the ones nowadays
are all kind of the same
and very expected.
This were really unexpected.
- [Girl] Yeah, watching
any horror movie in a dark
basement alone would scare you.
I don't think there's any way
not to be scared from that.